après le discours de volodymyr zelensky
le président ukrainien qui appelle à une
réforme en profondeur
du fonctionnement des nations unies on
va y revenir longuement avec vous au
virgin et hertz mais d'abord le massacre
de boudhha il a été largement question
aussi lors de ce discours volodymyr
zelensky décrit la pire atrocité le pire
crime de guerre commis depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale en europe voilà il le
rend responsable les russes ça on le
savait depuis hier ils demandent que la
russie soit tenu responsable pour crimes
de guerre et puis il affirme avoir des
preuves irréfutables de la
responsabilité des russes oui absolument
il ne les a pas donné mais il a rappelé
que pour lui qui mentent ces personnes
qui avaient été exécutées il avait été l
avait été on particulier parce qu'elle
n'avait pas voulu collaborer avec les
autorités russes il a quand même aussi
par les eu d'exécutions sommaires de
viols et de violences sexuelles ça c'est
vraiment un terme qui revenue à
plusieurs reprises y compris le
secrétaire général des nations unies a
évoqué à évoquer ces violences sexuelles
est de plus en plus ça fait quelques
jours qu'on entend parler de cette
thématique et que les des témoignages
dans ce sens émerge donc anthony blinken
qui dénonce aussi une campagne délibérée
pour tuer torturer et violer et violet
exactement pour en revenir donc à butch
à ce que dit ce que dit effectivement
volodymyr zelensky c'est qu'il a des
preuves irréfutables
on sait que les autorités russes ont dit
qu'il s'agissait d'une mise en scène des
autorités ukrainiennes en pointant le
fait que l' alerte avait été donnée
après largement après le départ des
russes or d'après les images satellites
des images satellites américaine ces
corps qui étaient dans cette rue
centrale à bout de chats étaient déjà là
alors que alors que les russes n'avaient
pas encore n'avait pas encore quitté la
ville de toute façon ce cadet vladimir
hiadlovsky c'est que le site était
ouvert à des enquêteurs à des
journalistes à des enquêteurs
indépendants et on sait que plusieurs
investigations vont être menées par les
nations unies part allouée à la demande
du conseil des droits de l'homme mais
également plusieurs enquêtes vont être
menées par
la cour pénale internationale ainsi que
par des juridictions nationales sous
enfin sur le principe d'après le
principe de la compétence universelle
voilà donc pour ce côté
sur le terrain sur son bout de chat
volodymyr zielinski qui a rappelé
l'article 1 de la charte des nations
unies savoir préserver la paix la paix
n'est pas préservée aujourd'hui et ils
le demandent donc une conférence
internationale à kiev pour qu'on puisse
réformer
les nations unies le système
international mondial et notamment sa
passe par l'exclusion de la russie en
tout cas en temps de guerre alors c'est
tout le paradoxe finalement de volodia
venir zelensky qui s'adresse au conseil
de sécurité des nations unies parce que
c'est un conseil de sécurité qui je vous
rappelle à cinq membres permanents les
états unis la chine la russie la france
le royaume uni les cinq vainqueurs entre
guillemets de la deuxième guerre
mondiale qui ont un droit de veto c'est
à dire que toute décision qui va être
prise peut être bloquée par l'un de ses
membres est le paradoxe c'est que
évidemment la russie étant partie
prenante de ce conflit elle peut bloquer
toute décision allemand allant dans ce
sens allant dans ce sens donc ce que
propose ce que fait remarquer le
président zelensky c'est que d'une part
ce système est à bout de souffle et ne
fonctionne pas et ne fonctionne pas pour
préserver la paix la paix et on l'a vu
lors de comptes de deux conflits
précédents que ce soit en syrie ou
ailleurs il y a souvent une partie
prenante ou l'allié d'un parties
prenantes au conflit qui va bloquer une
résolution une résolution de l'onu donc
ce que propose le président russe est un
mécanisme qui vous exclure et le membre
de sécurité membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité qui a impliqué dans
un conflit au moment de la prise de
décision et sachant que ça ne va
probablement pas se faire deux dits
qu'il faut faire une réforme sur le long
terme et alors cette proposition c'est
un serpent de mer en fait au niveau des
nations unies on sait que plusieurs pays
le demande des puissances émergentes
comme par exemple l'inde il ya aussi
plusieurs pays africains qui demande
aussi d'être représenté dans un dans un
siège permanent en revanche la france et
le royaume uni block décalé de faire
donc c'est pas forcément une idée qui va
être très populaire parmi les
occidentaux mais qui peut trouver de
l'écho parmi les autres